okay so no major blackout in the
foreseeable future but still there are
many questions about Germany's green
energy revolution so let's bring in
someone who can shed some light on the
subject Patrick gricean is an energy
expert of the think tank Angora in a
give vendor which translated with mean
energy revolution or energy turn around
now it's good to have you with us first
assault tell me a bit briefly what's the
state of Germany's energy revolution is
everything going according to plan well
it is progressing there are obviously
obstacles around the along the way which
we have to which we have to deal with
but we are now a 25-percent renewables
in the electricity sector that's quite
something let me give you some obstacles
for example since Bullins decision to
fate a nuclear power coal-fired power
plants are back in fashion that meets
lignite and hard coal not exactly known
to be environmentally friendly so how
does this fit in with Germany's green
energy targets well we are progressing
in terms of renewables we are
progressing in terms of phase out of
nuclear but when it comes to coal and
gas actually there is a mistake in the
system and that's essentially our and a
given our energy Turner odd focuses on
renewables and nuclear and the question
whether coal or gas is more competitive
we have left to Europe to the European
emissions trading system okay which also
as we heard in the report is a big
problem because the sort of counteracts
anything that you achieve in reducing
co2 emissions and the prices are too low
in the European emissions trading system
so it's rather the thing that we
together with our neighbors need to fix
the European emissions trading system so
that coal and gas are back into normal
which brings me to the next big question
of course I mean politics plays a big
role we see this also right now with
this big standoff between Russia and the
West energy security independence is
back high on the agenda and there's even
talk now in Brussels about the
possibility of shale gas production
which means fracking again not
environmentally friendly
how does that all go together well I
think the future will be a renewable
based energy system not only in Germany
but in the rest of Europe because wind
and solar have become very cheap
technologies and that's what we will all
go for when it comes to low-carbon
obviously we'll need some fossils and
that might be some gas either from
Norway or from UK or from the US and its
it is the question of the right energy
mix then Patrick Ryan thank you very
much for being here today thank you